what up space fam golson here from anime
out pro back at it again to discuss
demon slayer and this time i thought it
would be fun to analyze and break down
the new demonstrator entertainment
district arc outro i loved it when i saw
it and it surprised me how much they
included for those of us paying
attention so get hyped as we jump into
all of the hidden meanings and clues for
what's about to come but first if you do
enjoy seeing these demonstrator videos
on the channel and want to keep them
coming you know what to do set your
heart ablaze like my boy rang goku and
smash that like button with no mercy
zero mercy remember smashing that like
button is hashira energy and passing his
demon king of pop energy so you know
choose wisely if you haven't make this
the video you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on you guessed
it all notifications or you will miss
future demonstrator videos and updates
that's just the way it works and feel
free to leave suggestions in the
comments for future demonstrator topics
you are burning up to see and while you
wait for the next episode to drop feel
free to check out my huge and growing
demonstrator playlist that includes
videos on all the hashira demon moons
most recently on how strong upper moon 1
is and much more linked to that is in
the description and now without further
ado let's jump into its spoilers and all
so the outro starts with tundra holding
on to it and goku's sword guard i love
that detail and it symbolizes rengoku's
lasting presence and how tundra
inherited his will of fire if you will
in the first episode we see how senjuro
rengoku's brother wanted tundra to have
it in a way making him a symbolic suguko
aka hashira successor to rangoku and
that's pretty perfect tundra said before
that if you help someone you become a
part of them and their victories are
your victories too since rengoku saved
tundra inosuke and zenitsu now all of
their future victories will be his too
in a way and this guard that tundra will
be carrying around for the rest of the
series reminds us of that constantly
people's will and their impact don't die
just because they're killed what they
did in life continues to ripple
throughout eternity and we'll definitely
see that with rengoku next we see
tangent and his three wives tangent just
looking like a complete boss and all of
his wives are super cute he's actually
going to look for these three wives who
were undercover in the entertainment
district and suddenly stopped responding
in fact one might argue he was so rude
in the beginning of the arc because
maybe he's so worried about his wives
and yes you can imagine how upset and
jealous zanetsu is when he hears that
this dude who he views as a kidnapping
weirdo has not one but three ninja wives
we then see shots of all of our main
characters for this arc including
inosuke zanitsu tanjonesuko and of
course the sound hashira tengen not big
spoilers here but beautiful fireworks
that help capture the exciting world of
the entertainment district which is in
stark contrast to the more natural
settings we are usually used to seeing
in this series we also see tanjiro and
tangen looking at each other and then
carrying off in the same direction this
detail hints at how these two will work
together down the line in this arc and
beat the main bad guy we'll get into who
that is when he shows up in a bit
because he does show up in this outro
but yeah these are the two big stars but
zanitsu inosuke and nezuko will all play
big supporting roles as well in this arc
and especially nezuko will get some
really cool moments and we'll get to
that in a bit as well it's funny seeing
the three demon slaying
reacting to the busy district in their
own unique ways tanjiro a country
bumpkin as i too called him is feeling
culture shock and looking around
surprised saints was blushing clearly
excited by the fact that he's in an
entertainment district because you know
he's crazy about women and inosuke the
furthest removed from city living since
he grew up in nature with animals is
experiencing the worst culture shock and
you can tell he's freaked out by the way
he's moving and the sweat coming through
his bore mask he also knocks out a
random guy without noticing or caring
which is so enosuke and such a nice
touch you could miss if you're not
paying attention you see tangent looking
down from the rooftops which is what he
will be doing before the fight commences
tangent will be monitoring the situation
from above in order to infiltrate the
three demon ser amigos as i mentioned
we'll have to dress as girls and we see
tundra doing so here with all the ladies
looking at him and smiling tundra will
be very helpful as is shown with him
carrying the stuff in an excited way i
absolutely love how even though this has
nothing to do with his warrior training
he just throws himself into it and works
so hard in the manga when he finishes a
task he immediately asks for what else
he could help with and so it's no
surprise that people love having him
around tundra is just like the best guy
ever zanitsu of course is shown making
trouble instead of helping which will
reflect his personal experience as well
we see him playing an instrument to the
girls and then getting reprimanded for
it by a bossy lady we also see his
classic over the top freaking out face
which annoys some people but you get
used to it and then finally we see
inosuke and his girly face after they
remove the makeup on him they actually
think they got a really good deal
because he's so pretty so you don't see
him with the wacky makeup that you see
the other two with he's also looking
around the corner emphasizing the fact
that he's actually doing his job and
checking stuff out like a spy should we
see tangent in a flashback with what
looked like fallen soldiers and blood
that's actually his own backstory he
used to be a ninja and was trained by
his father in merciless ways him and his
siblings were taught to use people as
weapons and tools including their wives
i won't go into it too much here but
i'll say that most of tengan's eight
other siblings died and tengen was
sickened by the whole system and left
with his wives this early experience
changed him and he went from sort of
being a ruthless blending in ninja to
being the caring flashy guy he is today
and yes some of you might be shocked
when i say caring but you'll see for
instance he told his wives to prioritize
their own lives over any mission and
that was the complete opposite of what
they would have been taught in the
ruthless shinobi village the backstory
was sort of glossed over in the arc so i
hope this part means we'll be getting
some extended scenes in the anime of
what happened we then see muzon who is
not super relevant in this arc but hey
you want to show the big bad guy to hype
people up i suppose and he is always
looming over everything that's happening
so it makes sense after all upper moon
6daki who we'll see really soon is
working under him technically so why not
have the boss there and then docky
herself is shown dressed up in her
geisha outfit now technically she's not
a geisha but to be safer for youtube
i'll just call her a geisha first it
shows her like she could be any ordinary
geisha but then it zooms in on her mouth
and you see her demonic smile and then
her sashes fly all over the place which
is a clue to her blood demon art powers
which revolve around controlling these
sashes like a more attractive doctor
octavius then we see tundra and zainto
running and of course antu is sleeping
as usual showing how he'll sleep through
this fight as well while kicking butt i
also like how zenitsu with his thunder
powers looks a lot like pikachu with the
makeup i don't think that was a
coincidence and i appreciate the mangaka
doing that it's a hilarious look and a
great homage all four of our fighters
are shown running towards the upper moon
6 lady with the sashes and tangent is
shown easily dodging them now in the
manga there isn't this moment exactly
but it does reflect what happens well in
the sense that tangent is way stronger
than daki he cuts off her head in an
instant in the manga so in both cases
tangent is effortlessly able to outclass
her here he's just smiling and dancing
around her attacks you see daki's demon
outfit which is very fitting for the
entertainment district and then you see
nezuko with vines appearing around her
this is a hint to something huge that
happens nezuko is going to get a new
form where she hits maturity like a
brick wall and develops a lot very
quickly and this new form definitely
fits well into this arc as a whole it is
characterized by a horn on her head but
also these kinds of vine like patterns
on her body we see more fighting and
specifically if you slow it down blades
of blood approaching tengen now he is
more worried and that's because this is
the attack of a stronger demon than daki
we then see this stronger demon in
pretty good detail if you slow it down
you see his yellow eyes green hair and
his unique body you also see his sickle
weapons so the story behind this is that
this is gyutaro the older brother of
daki and part of the upper moon 6 team
once daki is wrecked by tangent and i
mean wrecked you taro the much stronger
of the two emerges from her body and the
key to defeating them is to cut off both
of their heads at the same time a detail
i like because it pretty much guarantees
you're going to need teamwork to beat
them rather than just one strong
individual but the blood blades chasing
down tangent are pointing to gyutaro's
blood demon art which lets him launch
these blood blades and even control them
in midair after they are launched we
then see tundra join tangent again for
shouting the fact that they will take on
gyutaro together because tengen despite
being a hashira is not strong enough to
do it alone even if this is the weakest
upper moon we see an explosion in the
distance which is perhaps a hint to
tengen's breath style where he usually
causes explosions by cutting tiny bombs
with his blades it's a very unique style
not to mention flashy style among the
hashira and i really like its uniqueness
and that's pretty much it for the
notable spoilers at the end you do see
tundra using sun breathing aka the dance
of the fire god but i think everyone
knew he'd use it again and obviously it
will be a key factor in this upcoming
fight but yeah hope you enjoyed this
video i don't usually make these kinds
of videos analyzing an opening or outro
but this one was so great and they added
in so many huge things and spoilers that
i couldn't resist talking about it in
greater detail what do you think of it
did you like it do you think they added
too much of what's gonna happen anyways
if you do enjoy seeing these demon serve
videos on the channel and want to keep
them coming then you know what to do set
your heart ablaze and smash that like
button with no mercy remember smashing
that like button is hashira energy and
passing is demon king of pop energy so
choose wisely if you haven't make this
the video subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
demonstrator videos and updates that's
just the way it works and there will
definitely be a lot of videos and
updates as the new season is airing feel
free to leave suggestions in the
comments for demonstrate topics you are
burning up to see that i haven't covered
yet and while you wait for the next
episode to drop feel free to check out
my huge and growing demon server
playlist that includes videos on all
hashira demon moons most recently on how
strong upper moon 1 is and much more
link to that is in the description and i
especially want to thank the patron
squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible first and foremost i want
to thank the patron of legend the one
acknowledged by lord wigo himself alpha
sigma and other one tier patrons the
ones who stand on top all clans ingrata
al jatal pate hepa the red haired fox
hinokami and water the toasted chi corey
mcgowan the spike lonely dakar dylan
isadore spidey life tinnell tungsten
tarkis big buddhist jeremy cummings and
che a whitley and our pro hero tier
patrons the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel cruz very gucci alicia
actor bonnie parks joanne garcia fat boy
games kind of might be a duck jessica
rabbit jeremy phillips ali baitnia and
temple thank you all so much if you do
enjoy our work you can support more of
it by going over to patreon.com anime
uproar and becoming a patron today for
as little as one dollar if you do so you
get your name feature in future videos
alongside these amazing people right
here and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course
thank meme so check out patreon.com
anime upload link in the description if
you're interested you can also join the
youtube channel by clicking that blue
join button next to the subscribe button
that you've hopefully already destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
support us you can get the same great
benefits thanks again and until next
time see you space cowboys
[Music]
you